une semaine pour se souvenir se souvenir
de l'abolition de l'esclavagé
à quelques jours de la date anniversaire
du 10 mai plusieurs manifestations sont
organisées à saint quentin en yvelines
sportifs comme culturel en fil rouge
cette année la lutte des classes
une exposition était d'ailleurs consacré
au porte-parole nelson mandela le
meilleur promoteur pour illustrer les
luttes qui qui ont permis de sortir de
l' esclavage de sortir de de
l'asservissement de tout asservissement
qu'elle compte lors de cette première
journée un stand a particulièrement
retenu l'attention celui du cm98
l'association milite pour un travail de
mémoire et de réconciliation le
collectif a créé une base de données
pour permettre aux descendants
d'esclaves de retrouver leurs racines
une base qui compte 120 millions
permettre à tous les antillais qui le
veulent mais les guyanais aussi les
réunionnais puisque nous avons des bases
de données qui permettent à partir du
nom patronymique du nom de famille de
savoir si les personnes à qui on sinon
aujourd'hui est esclave en 1848
parce qu'en général les noms ont été
donnés dont à l'évolution des statuts
qui n'en avaient pas une avec un numéro
et un prénom et leur a donné des noms de
famille à l'abolition de l'esclavagé
donc chacun ici en donnant son nom de
famille peut savoir si un incident qui a
reçu seulement là et en quelle année
quel âge il avait ça aide à structurer
un peu les choses et j'ai eu là une
jeune femme tout jeune femme de 18 ans
qui découvrait cette histoire était
complètement interloquée et je crois que
c'est le point de départ mais d'une
nouvelle conscience belles prises deux
prochains de choix et de son rôle dans
la société au fond
la sixième édition se termine à dimanche
pendant toute cette semaine des films
des expositions et des tables rondes
seront proposés attrape la verrière et
montigny le bretonneux
une cérémonie de commémoration a lieu
samedi matin place de la perdre